let's say we're studying a very small
and over simplified country that only
sells
only sells apples and we measured the
gdp in year one
in gdp in year one and we measure that
gdp as a thousand dollars and all of
that is due to apples and we also know
that the price of apples in year one
were 50 cents a pound so i'll write it
as 50
50 cents
per
pound and let's say that we are now year
one has gone by and even year two has
gone by and we're able to measure the
gdp in year two so gdp
in year two is
twelve hundred dollars and the price of
apples in year two let's just say it is
55 cents a pound
55 cents a pound so my question to you
is
gdp the whole point of measuring gdp is
measuring the productivity of a country
i mean we're measuring in terms of
dollars but we care more about just the
dollar amount we really care is was this
country
more productive and if it was more
productive how much more productive was
it and if we just look at these gdp
numbers right over here this thousand
dollars versus 1200 it gives you the
sense that well at least if you just
look at the numbers twelve hundred is
twenty percent larger than one thousand
dollars so if you just look at those
numbers right over there it looks like
the gdp grew by 20 percent but is that
an accurate representation of the
productivity of this country did it
actually produce 20 more goods and a big
clue is looking at this price here
because some of this gdp actually might
have increased just due to price but
that doesn't actually make the the
country more productive the quantity the
extra quantity of apples that the
country produces is actually what adds
to the total productivity one way to
think about it let me draw a little
diagram over here let me draw a little
diagram on this axis i'll do quantity on
this axis i will do price
and
p1 so if i want to figure out the gdp in
year one i would have the price of
apples in year one that's the only good
or service just to simplify things times
the quantity of apples in year one and
then this right over here the area of
this green rectangle would be gdp in
year one gdp in year one
and then gdp in year two would be the
price in year two so we're gonna go from
50 cents to 55 cents
the price in year two times the quantity
in year two we'll assume some growth has
occurred times the quantity in year two
and so gdp in year two would be this in
the area of this entire rectangle and if
we want to find the difference between
gdp and year two and gdp and year one it
would be the difference in area so it
would be what i am shading in in blue
right over here and based on the numbers
that we went over right over here the
area that i'm shading in in blue
so the difference between gdp and year
two and gdp in year one the area i'm
shading in blue would be would be this
200 the 200 increment that would be the
so this area right over here would be
that 200. now when you look at it over
here you see that that 200 some of it is
due to an increase in quantity
some of it is due to an increase in
quantity but a lot of it is also due to
an increase in price
so if we really wanted to figure out how
much more productive the quantity the
country got and we still want to measure
gdp in dollars maybe we can take a
measure of gdp that measures year two's
gdp but it does it in year one's prices
so if we could somehow multiply if we
could multiply year two's quantity by
year one's prices then we would get this
rectangle right over here we would get
this rectangle right over here and then
the difference between that and year one
would give us the incremental gdp
in year one prices due to quantity and
that's what we care about we care about
total productivity when we're thinking
about gdp we want to say how much more
productive did the country get
so let's try to do it with these numbers
with these numbers right over here so we
can figure out quantity two we could
figure out the quantity in year two just
by dividing the gdp by the price just by
dividing this area of the entire blue
rectangle and dividing it by the price
that'll give us the quantity so if we
divide 1200 divided by 55 cents let me
get my calculator out
so if i do
if i do 1200
divided by 55 cents this is my quantity
of apples and pounds in year two and
i'll just round it
21.82
so this is 21.82 so the quantity
in year two is 2182 pounds
21.82 pounds and then i could so this is
equal to that and then i could multiply
this times the price so this is this
quantity
2182 pounds and then i can multiply it
times the price in year one a year once
price so i'm going to multiply it times
p1 is equal to 50 cents a pound
50 cents
per pound
and this will give me so let me just get
my calculator i should be able to do
that one in my head but let's see 0.5
and i get 10 90 i'll just say 10 i'll
round it to 1091. so this is equal to
91. and this is an interesting number so
this is you could view this as
year
year two's
gdp
g
in
year or adjusted four all right adjusted
for
adjusted
prices or adjusted for price increases
or you could say in
year one prices
in
year
one prices
and what's useful about this is this
says look if prices had remained
constant this is how what our gdp would
have gotten to if prices did not
increase our gdp would have gotten to
this 1091 1091 is this area that i drew
in pink here and so now you can say if
prices were held constant the growth in
gdp
the growth in gdp would have been 91
not 200 so this p this area right over
here that i'm actually let me do it in a
color let me do it in orange maybe this
area right over here
the actual growth if prices were held
constant would have been 91 would have
gone from 1 000 of gdp to 1091
so this right over here that area is 91
of and we could even call it real growth
real growth it really measures the
productivity now this gives us an
interesting i guess set of ideas one
idea is to just measure your gdp in the
current year's dollars so this was gdp
measured in year two's dollars it was
year two gdp measured in year two
dollars year two prices so we could call
that year two's nominal
gdp
nominal gdp nominal in name so it's gdp
a name in that year's prices but this
right over here where we measured year
two's gdp in some base year's prices so
it allows a real comparison of of how
much did our productivity actually
increase our productivity actually
increased by nine percent we produced
nine percent more apples this we call
real gdp
real
real gdp because it gives you a measure
of real productivity it tries to take
out price increases but we'll see in the
future or we might not do it in an
introductory course but in practice it's
kind of hard to really measure what the
absolute you know if you wait every this
was a simple economy where we only had
where we only had one product but if you
have many many many products like you
know gazillions of products in a real
economy and their prices are adjusting
and their quantities are adjusting it's
not so easy to figure out how to adjust
for price but
the the the folks running the national
income accounts do try to do this so
they get a sense of how much was the
actual real growth